[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in Rebecca Lowe NBC Sports
Premier League hosts the voice of reason
by the way you uh joining us to talk
some World Cup and uh she joins us on
the program
one week ago today
one week one week ago today yeah
USA England
can we talk about the future
who are you rooting for
you know who I was rooting for you know
full well who I was rooting for England
correct by the way that poll that poll
is brilliant and and everyone is correct
Saturday is the only day of Interest
this weekend I mean I'm finally feeling
like you your listeners this country
they're understanding the beautiful game
if the United States beats the
Netherlands
fill in the blank after that
well then a they go to the quarterfinals
and that will be I'm not I can't
remember the bracket who they possibly
could play against but the bigger issue
there or not issue but the bigger effect
is
the amount of coverage that will get in
this country the step forward that that
will be for this team and this sport in
this country and you know I'm more about
growing the game Dan Patrick I'm all
about growing the game so go USA
if england had lost to the United States
yeah
but would have happened yeah what would
have happened well nothing really in
terms of the effect of it because USA
would probably have gone through as
group winners and England would still
have beaten Wales because Wales were
rubbish and would have gone through
seconds so England would have played
Netherlands and USA would have been
Senegal I actually think Netherlands
might be an easier type than Senegal so
you know if we lost the USA you know
there would have been some major inquest
situations going on in England but we've
forgotten it very quickly just like I'm
over it already I don't even know why
you brought it up because Wales we
smashed them and now we're into the
losses okay so we're just all about the
future Dan Patrick all right sometimes
it's just a hypothetical a what if
scenario that's on that's it we deal in
hypotheticals here well I've got but
that's good for you what if you weren't
so excited about Neil Neil with England
I mean what if you know guys calm down
okay how about this let's say Christian
pulisic got hurt and you were in England
and you were describing it for the BBC
with this I did not lead with this
it's been funny every time I come on the
show we either swear or we talk about a
part of the anatomy which we just don't
need to talk about or we talk about
rubbers pencil erasers
um uh policits um
um nether regions
okay but that's not really British is
nether regions like I'm I'm thinking how
would you describe it if you were home
well if I was on television in England I
would probably say you know the lower
part of the pelvis I'm not we you know I
wouldn't I'd have to be very careful I
wouldn't say what you are
talking I'm not I'm not having you say
bollocks I'm not or wanker I'm not doing
that I I said and I'm not saying that
you I you're on the BBC they would say
these things wouldn't they they would
not
down absolutely Sky Sports but Sky
Sports no no one is saying the b word no
one is
so we don't say that say that day the
nether region okay or the lower section
of the pelvis okay
okay all right fair enough uh how
important do you think that goal was for
Christian pulisic as far as how we view
him you know the big stage uh probably
has been a disappointment uh in the
Premier League but that was a a one of
the biggest goals we've ever had
yeah I you're spot on you're absolutely
spot on his time at Chelsea has been
disappointing down on a number of levels
he's not had enough game time when he
does come in he sometimes makes an
impact sometimes doesn't he just cannot
command a starting position in that
Chelsea lineup they now have a new
manager in Grand Potter so that may
change but going into this world cup he
hadn't had a lot of minutes under his
belt and he's really injury prone so
going into this world cup it was all
about pulisic as the gem palific is the
star of this team can he step up and
that is a question that we ask about so
many soccer players going into the World
Cup is the star player gonna step up and
so far to be fair to him he is showing
us at this world cup why Chelsea paid so
much money for his services and why he
should be at best league in the world
which is the Premier League and I wonder
about this we talk about it in sports
here in the United States of having that
experience going through something I
think they're the second youngest team I
think Ghana is the youngest team and uh
Iran was the oldest team I I wonder
about that experience in world World Cup
as opposed to you know something like
the Premier League
yeah and I think
I think right because the world cup is
it's a very
and very few players get to play more
than just one when you're young you just
don't have as much fear in anything Dan
you know whether you're at school and
you're going out you know partying on a
weekend you don't have that fear that
say like you have when you were 30 years
old when you're like oh I'm not going to
go to that particular party that's why
young people make mistakes so they don't
have the fear this young American team
doesn't have the fear it doesn't have
the experience they feel like they have
nothing to lose even though there will
always be pressure on them especially
with the um the World Cup coming to the
United States in four years of time but
I think the youth is what's driving this
team
time to play know your Netherlands
are you ready
oh always
I'm always right and I said Netherlands
okay
um you did say that yes I did Paulie the
first question for Rebecca Lowe on know
your Netherlands okay uh what did the
Netherlands used to be called
Holland correct all right and Paulie I
feel like if you're from the 90s like me
then you still call them Holland but
you're probably not allowed to I think
it's it's frowned upon it is okay I
better not then I better all right next
question no you're Netherlands all right
uh if you are from the Netherlands you
are blank
Dutch Dutch is correct all right they
get tough guys guys please they're gonna
get tougher this is not this is not as
tough as the uh becoming American quiz
that we gave her three years ago yeah
yeah
um what was invented in the Netherlands
what was invented in the Netherlands
that's become something that's all over
the world and a big part of
the business side of the world
the business side of the world given
hints I mean it's that uh oh yeah that's
a massive hint I mean I have no idea be
part of the business so I'm not I mean
that's just not my area
stock market Dutch East India Trading
Company
okay here we go what else do we have
okay this is fill in the blank okay
there are more blank in Netherlands than
people there are more blank in
Netherlands than people
um
uh tulips goats clogs or all are correct
but we were looking for bicycles
bicycles tulips can be approved answer I
I said Bulldogs my answer was yeah my
history was clogs too okay everyone's
got two pairs the final question for
Rebecca Lowe know your Netherlands okay
there are four possible answers Name a
famous person who is from the
Netherlands or ancestors are from the
Netherlands and
and no hints not not a footballer not a
football I do football no oh do me a
thing Rue van nesselroy do you wanted to
go there didn't you
I
uh oh you did not okay no but you'll
acknowledge honestly continues to
Astound me yes
um no I was gonna go for
um
Johan Cruyff obviously because he's
incredibly famous but in terms of an I
think there was a was it the guy in The
Sound of Music from was he me that I
basically I don't know basically I just
haven't got a lot of Dutch people
shockingly we're gonna accept that a guy
from The Sound of Music was Dutch
yes we are done yes we are my
Netherlands we always we would have
taken Rucker Hower Vincent van Gogh
Rembrandt or Eddie Van Halen
you need to know your Netherlands don't
worry about mine no we know our
Netherlands I said Van Gogh yeah
uh what would you give up for England to
win the World Cup
not so much done it's a great question I
mean take my house I I I I I really
believe that if england oh God it's just
it makes me sweaty thinking about it if
England win the World Cup it will rank
as the top three days of my life
can't save the order but it's going to
rank in that top three it will be it
will and by the way we're going to
England to restart the Premier League on
boxing day December the 26th from
Arsenal so we're going over as a family
or next week week after so we're going
to be there should it happen should
England get to the final we will be in
England I'm going to be right in the
middle of that Carnage right in the
middle of Oxford Circus that's where
you're going to find me in amongst the
Carnage all right so your marriage your
son Teddy
and winning the World Cup in no
particular order I'm guessing having
your son
England wins the World Cup
and then and then getting married
in no particular order down I couldn't
possibly call it
okay maybe it's winning the World Cup
anybody can get married a lot of people
have kids
yeah England doesn't win the World Cup
exactly England Teddy
and then getting married
I have a question for you okay what what
what do you think USA getting to the
quarterfinals would do for football in
this country
I think they'd have to go a step further
semi-finals do you think yeah yeah final
four I you know we we view it like March
Madness where you have these surprises
in March Madness and then you get to the
final four and that's where the real
teams show up I think getting to the
final four no matter what happened after
that and then four years down the road
you know the second youngest team at
this world cup now you got that
Experience Momentum interest in the
United States do you need I mean if if
you need me you want me to help you you
know and it's on you know that I can do
NFL just as well as you can do soccer
interchangeable that's not we're not we
shouldn't be bragging about that that's
not a that's not a good thing uh it's
great to talk to you safe travels
um go England
go England go USA go both of them
there's so much love between you know as
Harry Kane goes England goes that's it
Harry Kane
once again Christian pulisic got hit in
the nether region uh thank you Rebecca
you're welcome thank you I love making
her blush I do I I love making her I
like that you're like what would you say
on BBC oh they would say okay what Sky
Sports Sky Sports would say it though
right
damn it will you tell me what I want to
hear okay no but what about Sky Sports
they definitely would right
I was going there I've waited four
questions in before I went there